>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
TULSI GABBARD WON
DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S PRIMARY TEN
YEARS AGO SHE WON THE SEAT.
MIGHT BE THE MOST LIBERAL OUT OF
ALL 50 STATES, HAWAII.
IT'S A DEMOCRATIC STATE.
HAS NOT VOTED FOR REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE NEARLY 40
YEARS.
IF YOU GET ELECTED AS A DEMOCRAT
IN HAWAII IT'S NOT EXACTLY
BREAKING NEWS.
I MET ONE TULSI GABBARD WON THE
PRIMARY AND THE SEAT THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL PARTY TOOK A
DEEP INTEREST IN HER AND YOU CAN
SEE WHY.
A SMART, APPEALING 31-YEAR-OLD
WHO KNEW WHAT SHE BELIEVED I
COULD IT FLUENTLY.
SHE WAS ALSO AN IRAQ WAR
VETERAN.
TULSI GABBARD WAS NEAR-PERFECT
AND THEY GOT IT.
BARACK OBAMA ENDORSED HER RIGHT
AWAY.
NANCY PELOSI CALLED HER
PERSONALLY AND INVITED
TULSI GABBARD TO SPEAK ON THE
OPENING NIGHT OF THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL CONVENTION IN -- AND
SHE WAS SWORN IN, THEY NAMED HER
VICE CHAIR OF THE NATIONAL
PARTY.
SHE HAD JUST GOTTEN THERE.
SHE WAS VICE CHAIR OF THE DNC.
THE MEDIA PLAYED ITS PRESCRIBED
ROLE.
IF NANCY PELOSI LIKES IT, SO DO
THEY.
FARMING PROFILE AFTER FAWNING
PROFILE EMERGED.
IF YOU LIVED IN WASHINGTON, HE
REMEMBERED IT VERY WELL.
THE FUTURE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, TULSI GABBARD.
CASEY DON'T REMEMBER, HERE'S A
SELECTION.
>> WATCH OUT FOR THE NEXT
SUPERSTAR.
>> HERE WE GO.
>> TULSI GABBARD.
>> TULSI GABBARD IS A RISING
STAR IN THIS PARTY.
TULSI GABBARD SHOULD BE HERE
TONIGHT.
WE DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH YOUNG
VETERANS IN THIS PARTY, ENOUGH
YOUNG WOMAN, PEOPLE OF COLOR.
>> YOU ARE CONSIDERED A RISING
STAR IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
YOU HAD A POSITION OF LEADERSHIP
IN THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE.
>> HER STORY IS TAILOR-MADE FOR
HOLLYWOOD.
I HALF EXPECT NATALIE PORTMAN TO
BE VYING FOR THE ROLE.
THIS STORY IS NOT TO BE
BELIEVED.
>> TULSI GABBARD IS GOING TO BE
THE ONE TO WATCH TONIGHT.
>> TOLD C GABBARD IS A IRAQ WAR
VETERAN.
YESTERDAY SHE WAS PROMOTED TO
MAJOR.
SHE IS A RISING STAR.
THE FACT THAT SHE'S NOT HERE FOR
WHATEVER REASON.
>> IN A BATTLE I WANT HER IN MY
TRENCH.
>> ME TOO.
>> Tucker: DID YOU HEAR THAT?
SHE IS A RISING STAR.
HOLLYWOOD IS GOING TO MAKE A
MOVIE ABOUT HER.
I WANT HER IN MY TRENCH.
IT'S PRETTY HARD TO BELIEVE NOW
THAT WAS THE ABSOLUTE CONSENSUS
AMONG DEMOCRATIC PARTY
SYCOPHANTS UNTIL 2016.
IN 2016S OF BY COMMAND FROM
ABOVE, THE FAWNING STOPPED
ABRUPTLY, REPLACED BY
SILENCE AND THEN HOWLS OF SCORN
RAGE.
WHAT HAPPENED IN 2016?
DONALD TRUMP WAS ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
A FEW DAYS LATER, DISPLAYING THE
INDEPENDENCE OF SPIRIT THE
DEMOCRATS CLAIM TO LOVE IN YOUNG
WOMEN BUT ACTUALLY DESPISE MORE
THAN ANYTHING, TULSI GABBARD
DECIDED TO TALK TO THE NEW
PRESIDENT ABOUT AN ISSUE THAT
SHE CARED ABOUT WHICH WAS U.S.
POLICY TOWARD SYRIA A COUNTRY
THAT AGAIN GABBARD WAS ALONE IN
POINTING OUT HAS AN AWFUL LOT OF
CHRISTIANS SO MAYBE WE SHOULD
PAY ATTENTION.
SHE PUT IT "I FELT IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH
PRESIDENT-ELECT.
NOW BEFORE THE DRUMBEATS OF WAR
THAT NEOCONS UP AND BEATING DRAG
US INTO AN ESCALATION OF THE WAR
TO OVERTHROW THE SYRIAN
GOVERNMENT."
YOU CAN'T SAY THAT IN
WASHINGTON.
MAYBE SHE DIDN'T KNOW.
THEY TOLD HER STOPPED.
LET THE ADULTS DO IT BUT GABBARD
DIDN'T SEEM TO CARE.
SHE WENT PERSONALLY TO SYRIA.
SHE WAS A MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
YOU CAN DO THAT.
IN SHORT IT TO SEE CONDITIONS
FOR SALE.
AND THEN WHILE SHE WAS THERE SHE
MET WITH THE SYRIAN PRESIDENT
BASHAR AL-ASSAD.
THAT WAS IT.
IT WAS OVER.
WHETHER TULSI GABBARD KNEW IT OR
NOT, HER CAREER AS A RISING STAR
WITHIN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY CAME
TO A COMPLETE ABRUPT AND FINAL
HALT.
SHE HAD DONE THE ONE THING
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO DO,
COMMITTED THE ONE UNFORGIVABLE
SIN WHICH WAS TO QUESTION PERMIT
WASHINGTON'S FOREIGN POLICY.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT AND EVERYONE
KNOWS IT.
IF YOU LOOK AROUND YOU CAN SEE
THAT NO ONE DOES DO IT.
THEY ALWAYS TELL YOU HOW RADICAL
SANDY CORD AS IS, RASHIDA TLAIB.
WOULD THEY DO THAT?
NO.
AOC MAY BE A SOCIALIST BUT IN
THE END, SHE IS WITH THE CRYSTAL
LENSES CHENEY ON TEAM RAYTHEON.
SHE DOES NOT CROSS THAT LINE
BECAUSE SHE'S NOT ALLOWED TO.
TULSI GABBARD IS SOMEONE WHO HAD
SERVED IN THE MILITARY, ELECTED
MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
DECIDED WHY SHOULDN'T I SAY WHAT
I THINK.
THAT'S WHAT SHE DID.
FOR DOING THAT, OVERNIGHT, HER
FELLOW DEMOCRATS ACCUSED
TULSI GABBARD, THE COMBAT AT HER
AND YOU'D WANT IN YOUR FOXHOLE,
OF COMMITTING TREASON AGAINST
THE COUNTRY SHE WAS SERVING.
HILLARY CLINTON WENT EVEN
FARTHER THAN THAT, SPEAKING OF
CONSPIRACY NUTS, SHE CLAIMED THE
RUSSIANS WERE GROOMING
TULSI GABBARD AS SOME KIND OF
MANCHURIAN CANDIDATE.
DO YOU WANT TO LISTEN TO LUNACY?
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> I'M NOT MAKING ANY
PREDICTIONS BUT I THINK THEY
HAVE GOT THERE I HAD SOMEONE
CURRENTLY IN THE DEMOCRAT OF
PRIMARY AND THEY ARE GROOMING
HER TO BE A THIRD-PARTY
CANDIDATE.
SHE'S A FAVORITE OF THE RUSSIAN.
>> Tucker: WAS SHE A CRISIS
ACTOR?
WHAT A LUNATIC.
NO ONE NOTICED BECAUSE EVERYONE
WAS SEEING IT.
THE "L.A. TIMES" WHICH AT
ONE POINT WAS AN ACTUAL
NEWSPAPER ACCUSED TULSI GABBARD
OF QUOTE TALKING LIKE A RUSSIAN
ASSET, MEDIA SPY.
SO THE YEARS WENT BY AND
TULSI GABBARD DECIDED TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT.
STILL AS A DEMOCRAT AS SHE HAD
BEEN IN HER ENTIRE TIME IN
CONGRESS.
SHE HAD ALWAYS BEEN A DEMOCRAT.
ADVISED HER OF THE DNC.
SHE WOUND UP IN A PRESIDENTIAL
DEBATE IN OCTOBER OF 2019 AND
SHE RESPONDED TO THIS.
WATCH.
>> "NEW YORK TIMES" AND CNN HAVE
ALSO SMEARED VETERANS LIKE
MYSELF FOR CALLING FOR AN END TO
THIS REGIME CHANGE.
TODAY'S AGO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" PUT OUT AN
ARTICLE SAYING THAT I AM A
RUSSIAN ASSET AND THE SOD
APOLOGIST AND ALL THESE DIFFERE.
THIS MORNING CNN COMMENTATOR
SAID I AM AN ASSET OF RUSSIA.
COMPLETELY DESPICABLE.
AS PRESIDENT, I WILL END THESE
REGIME CHANGE WARS BY DOING TWO
THINGS.
ENDING THAT DRACONIAN SANCTIONS
THAT ARE REALLY A MODERN-DAY
SEARS THE LIKES OF WHICH WE ARE
SEEING SAUDI ARABIA WAGE AGAINST
LLAMA THAT HAVE CAUSED TENS AND
THOUSANDS OF SYRIAN CIVILIANS TO
DIE AND STARVE AND I
WOULD MAKE SURE THAT WE STOP
SUPPORTING TERRORISTS LIKE
AL QAEDA IN SYRIA WHO HAVE BEEN
THE GROUND FORCE IN THIS ONGOING
REGIME CHANGE WAR.
>> Tucker: THEY CALLED HER A
RUSSIAN ASSET.
THAT SLUR IS SO COMMON THAT WE
DON'T REALLY THINK ABOUT IT.
THIS IS A TRANSPARENTLY
PATRIOTIC PERSON, ELECTED NUMBER
OF CONGRESS SERVING IN THE
U.S. ARMY WHO WAS ALSO BY THE
WAY ONE OF THE NICEST PEOPLE IN
ALL OF WASHINGTON WHO IS MAKING
TRADITIONALLY LIBERAL POINTS
ABOUT WAR.
NOT THAT ALL WARS ARE BAD OR WAR
IS NEVER NECESSARY.
SHE'S PARTICIPATED IN WARS
PERSONALLY.
SHE WAS MERELY SAYING AND HAS
SAID DOZENS OF TIMES ON
TELEVISION THAT WARS THAT DON'T
BENEFIT THE UNITED STATES ARE
PROBABLY A BAD IDEA FOR US TO
ENGAGE IN.
THAT'S ALL SHE SAID.
AND FOR THAT, SHE WAS RUN OUT OF
TOWN.
WHY IS THAT?
WHY IS IT SUCH AN ACCEPTABLE
THING TO SAY?
THERE IS A PATTERN HERE.
CERTAIN PEOPLE DO BENEFIT FROM
WARS AND THEY WANT MORE SO THREE
YEARS AFTER THAT DEBATE ANOTHER
U.S. FUNDED REGIME CHANGE WAR IS
UNDERWAY AND THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
THIS TIME OUR STATED GOAL IS
REMOVING NOT SOME THIRD WORLD
DICTATOR WHO MIGHT HAVE WMD BUT
REMOVING A GUY WHO WAS THE
WORLD'S LARGEST NUCLEAR
STOCKPILE.
6300 NUCLEAR WARHEADS.
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
ONCE AGAIN BECAUSE TULSI GABBARD
HAS QUESTIONED THE WISDOM OF
THIS COMPLETE LUNACY, DEMOCRATS
ARE ACCUSING HER OF WORKING FOR
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
SO IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ACTUALLY
BELIEVES, DON'T LISTEN TO WHAT
THEY SAY.
OH, WE WANT EMPOWERED WOMEN OF
COLOR WHO ARE ALSO VETERANS.
NO THEY DON'T.
THEY WANT PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT
REGIME CHANGE WARS.
THAT'S THEIR REDLINE.
THAT'S ONE THING THEY WILL BROOK
NO DISSENT ON WHATSOEVER.
THEY DON'T CARE WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT IT.
THEY DON'T WANT TO DEBATE YOU
WANTED.
IF YOU DISAGREE OR ASK
QUESTIONS, THEY GO RIGHT TO
TRADER.
TODAY TULSI GABBARD DID WHAT IS
PROBABLY INEVITABLE AND PROBABLY
HAS BEEN SINCE 2016.
SHE LEFT HER OWN PARTY, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
DON'T HAVE TO GUESS AS TO WHY
BECAUSE SHE EXPLAINED IT IN SOME
DETAIL.
PLEASES AND CAREFULLY TO THIS
BECAUSE IT'S INSPIRING AND
INTERESTING.
AND SHE DIDN'T ON THE NEW
PODCAST CALLED THE TULSI GABBARD
CHILDREN WATCH OR SHE IS.
>> CAN NO LONGER REMAIN IN
TODAY'S DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IT'S UNDER THE COMPLETE CONTROL
OF AN ELITIST CABAL OF
WARMONGERS DRIVEN BY COWARDLY
WOKENESS WHO DIVIDE US BY
RACIALIZING EVERY ISSUE AND
STOKING ANTIWHITE RACISM.
WHO ACTIVELY WORK TO UNDERMINE
OUR GOD-GIVEN FREEDOMS ENSHRINED
IN OUR CONSTITUTION AND WHO ARE
HOSTILE TO PEOPLE OF FAITH AND
SPIRITUALITY.
WHO DEMONIZED THE POLICE,
PROTECT CRIMINALS THE EXPENSE OF
LAW-ABIDING AMERICANS, WHO
BELIEVE IN OPEN BORDERS, WHO
WEAPONIZE THE NATIONAL SECURITY
STATE TO GO AFTER THEIR
POLITICAL OPPONENTS AND ABOVE
ALL, ARE DRAGGING US EVER CLOSER
TO NUCLEAR WAR.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE MAIN
REASONS I'M LEAVING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> Tucker: KEEP IN MIND UNTIL
TODAY THIS WAS A REGISTERED
DEMOCRAT, OFFICEHOLDER,
STANDARD-BEARER OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THE FUTURE OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
FROM THE COUNTRY'S MOST LIBERAL
STATE.
THIS WAS A LIBERAL DEMOCRAT.
DID YOU HEAR THAT?
IS THERE A SINGLE WORD YOU
DISAGREE WITH?
IS THERE A SINGLE WORD THAT THE
REPUBLICAN WHO REPRESENTS YOU
WHO YOU SEND MONEY TO A NEW BOAT
FORWARD REPEAT IN PUBLIC.
UNTIL YESTERDAY A MEMBER OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
SAYING THINGS AN OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF REPUBLICAN VOT